a young Minnesotan picks a bouquet in a 200 acre
garden south of Minneapolis actually the millions
of flowers blossoming in this trial ground
were not grown for decoration any more than
this corn being harvested on another Minnesota
farm is intended to be eaten both the pom-poms
and the corn were grown for seed stock purposes
seed that will be processed packaged and sold
by Northrop King and company largest general
seed house in the world as the wagon box is
filled its towed to the husking and sorting
tables we're snapping rolls remove the husk
the men not only take care of husks the machine
misses but also call out for the ears this corn
is only one of Northrop Kings many hybrids
it's called ks2 like other grains vegetables
and flowers it was developed for planting in a
specific part of the country where specific soil
and climatic conditions prevail at one of the
company's five plants that process corn alone
the truck load is transferred to drying bins
where hot air will drive the corn so it can be
safely stored through the winter sample kernels
are taken to be sent to Minneapolis for tests
that will show how the seed will germinate
when placed in the ground in the spring
after drying the corn is again
checked or off shape immature
or damaged ears and then the kernels are removed
at the seed laboratory in Minneapolis
sample seeds from all the different
processing plants are tested in terminators
which show what percentage will sprout and
grow in the case of these beans
it's 96 out of a hundred that's
important information for the grower
no matter what the size of his crop
also important is the reaction of
the seeds in this germinator which
duplicates conditions that will prevail
during a cold damp raw spring it suggests
how suitable the particular type of seed is
for early planting in that sort of climate
no home gardening enthusiasts ever devoted as much
attention to a sprout as thousands
get here every day root growth gets
particular attention well that tells how well
they'll progress after sprouting in the field
some seeds notably beans peas and corn must
be hand-picked to get rid of those considered
unsatisfactory the bad ones might be off
color or off shape have damaged seed coats
or show indications of blight or disease
how do they go here's a check on a sample
of oats the sharp-eyed young lady determines
the purity and trueness two type of the seeds
in the shipment just a few of the tests that go
on endlessly in addition there are several ways
in which the seeds can be cleaned and graded
mechanically and thus accurately labeled so
the buyer will know exactly what he's getting
they're sorted by size by weight shape and
diameter all for the purpose of eliminating
the hit or miss approach to agriculture
many seed houses concentrate on lawn seed let's
say or hybrid corn or flowers or vegetables
some aim at the market gardener others at the
home gardener here they do their best to serve
everybody who uses seeds for example these
seeds being automatically weighed out into
packets are obviously intended for the grower
who plants not for business but for pleasure
tiny scales inside measure out the right amount
to a fraction of an ounce the company handles
an extremely rare type of petunia whose
seeds cost a hundred and eighty dollars
an ounce but needless to say they're not
packaged like this and our seed producers
are concerned much less with such exotic
and expensive novelties than they are with
improving our basic horticultural supplying
us with the seeds we really need in greater
quantity in pure our strains at less
cost than was ever thought possible